[Music]
pikachu oh jeez hey little guy
how did you get in here i know
you can't understand me
but put down the stapler or i
will electrocute
you
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of rt
essentials i'm mark ellis here's the
deal people love video games and people
love movies and studios love adapting
video games into movies although for
some reason critics generally don't love
video game movies but they are hit with
the audiences well some of them of the
dozens and dozens of video game movies
only a handful have ever made it into
fresh territory on the tomato meter but
with video games more popular than ever
and plenty of film adaptations in the
pipeline at multiple studios the trend
ain't going anywhere so let's hit up up
down down left right left right ba start
on our controllers i think that gets us
30 lives in contra as i bring you the
list of the highest rated video game
movies ever by tomato meter and we're
doing it in ascending order from lowest
to highest i think i did that code right
hit the start button
final fantasy the spirit's within
ryan let's go
just what the hell do you think you're
doing there's a life form in here there
hasn't been life here in years well
there is now life form or not i'm taking
you in fine arrest me but i'm not
leaving without that life form
it's gonna be one of those days the
first film on this list of the highest
rated video game movies is at a rotten
44
you heard that right like i said the
critics just not fans all that much this
is final fantasy the spirits within the
2006 action adventure film is the only
directorial credit for hironobu
sakaguchi the creator of the final
fantasy franchise a franchise that hit
north america in 1990 on the good old
original nintendo the spirits within is
the first ever computer-generated
animated film with photorealistic
characters blurring the lines with
reality and computer animation and it
tells the story of earth pitted up
against mysterious alien phantoms that
take the energy from all living things
on the planet
so a scientist makes one last stand on
earth with the help of some ragtag
soldiers to fight off the invasion the
movie features the voices of ming na wen
alec baldwin donald sutherland james
woods ving rhames perry gilpin and steve
buscemi and with the aforementioned
photo realism post-production took four
years with roughly 200 people doing a
combined 120 years of work all while
using some of the most advanced
processing capabilities of the time
that's a big whoa so not surprisingly it
became the most expensive video game
inspired movie ever produced until the
release of prince of persia the sands of
time in 2010 i guess records are meant
to be broken don't leave me
you've been trying to tell me the death
isn't the end don't back out on me
now that i finally believe
[Music]
after exceeding its original budget and
ending with a final cost of 137 million
dollars the film grows just 85 million
dollars at the box office which was kind
of a bummer for columbia pictures since
it was their first animated feature
since the care bears movie to a new
generation back in 1986. did you know
that sure we all did the bright side for
the people who spent four years in post
is that the impressive visuals were not
the issue for the critics with a
consensus that final fantasy the spirits
within raises the bar for computer
animated movies but the story is dull
and emotionally removed
just like my personal life
mortal kombat 1995.
[Music]
flawless victory
[Music]
come to a little tournament he said
you're good for the career he said
yeah we're right if the final fantasy
franchise didn't transport you back to
your childhood maybe this next movie
will it's 95's classic mortal kombat
directed by paul w s anderson best known
as the creative voice behind the
resident evil film series this movie
follows lord raiden played by
christopher lambert who handpicks three
martial artists to mentor that includes
federal agent sonia blade played by
bridget wilson shao and monk liu kang
played by robin shu and action movie
sensation johnny cage played by lyndon
ashby after some intense training raiden
transports the trio to an
inter-dimensional fighting tournament to
take on the demonic warriors of the evil
shang tsung who is threatening to take
over the earth the film's story was
primarily adapted from the original 1992
video game but it also pulls elements
from mortal kombat 2 which came out the
following year
toasty and the cast could have looked
much different with cameron diaz
originally cast as sonia blade but
dropping out due to injury plus sean
connery was offered the role of ward
raiden but turned it down and
jean-claude van damme was offered johnny
cage oh that would have been awesome he
opted to make street fighter instead the
film ultimately grossed 122 million
dollars worldwide on a 20 million dollar
budget plus the soundtrack went platinum
and it spawned a sequel
not a good one mortal kombat
annihilation in 1997 which is clocking
in at four percent on the tomato meter
deservedly so there's also been an
animated sequel series a live action
prequel series a couple of animated
spin-off films starring joel mcgale and
a full-on live-action reboot in 2021
which we might get to later on this list
flawless victory but this original
couldn't quite please the critics like
the financial times is nigel andrews who
said it is too violent for children and
too silly for anyone else at an overall
critic's consensus that says despite an
effective otherworldly atmosphere and
appropriately cheesy visuals mortal
kombat suffers from its poorly
constructed plot laughable dialogue and
subpar acting not for me still the
greatest video game movie in my opinion
monster hunter
[Music]
oh my god
next up on our list which i swear we're
gonna get fresh later on i promise is
2020's monster hunter this one was
written directed and produced by paul w
sanderson yeah the mortal kombat guy and
based on the fantasy themed role playing
video game from capcom that first graced
our playstation twos back in 2004. the
film follows artemis played by mila
jovovich who's transported to a new
world along with her loyal soldiers and
ending up in a desperate battle for
survival against enormous monsters with
incredible power and to counter the
terrifying attacks she teams up with a
mysterious hunter who has found a way to
fight back this is the fifth time that
yovovich has worked with director
anderson who happens to be her husband
and the rest of the cast includes stars
like megan good diego banetta ron
perlman and rapper actor and now
comedian t.i
anderson has said that parts of the film
were based on a crossover event in the
game metal gear solid peace walker in
2010 where a military squad briefly
faced monsters from the monster hunter
series and some additional characters in
the movie are based on the more recent
game monster hunter world
hitting theaters in december of 2020
during the covet 19 pandemic the film
grows just over 44 million dollars
worldwide against a budget of 60 million
although both anderson and yovich have
expressed interest in doing a sequel at
some point in the future but sitting at
a rotten 45 percent this first
installment did not fare well with
critics with a consensus that says
monster hunter is mostly a mindless blur
of action held together by the
slenderous threads of dialogue and plot
and exactly what many viewers will be
looking for rampage
if you're looking for the right
inspiration to climb up the side of a
building and destroy it this next movie
is for you 2018's rampage the film was
directed by brad payton and marks his
third collaboration with dwayne the rock
johnson after journey to the mysterious
island and san andreas in this one
johnson stars as primatologist davis
okoye who shares an unshakable bond with
the very smart silverback gorilla george
which has been in his care since birth
but when a rogue genetic experiment goes
wrong they always seem to george grows
to a monstrous size along with a wolf in
a reptile and they begin a path of
destruction so davis teams up with a
discredited genetic engineer and the
military to try to prevent a global
disaster rampage is johnson's second
video game movie after 2005's doom and
also stars naomi harris male and
anchorman jack quade jake lacy joe
manganiello and jeffrey dean morgan and
george the gorilla is the only animal to
be played by an actor jason wiles while
the other two were created entirely
through key frame animation the film is
of course loosely based on the 1986
classic from midway games and has some
pretty great references to the arcade
favorite like when george eats a person
that he pulls out of a building he
punched and millen akerman's character
being devoured while wearing a red dress
[Music]
warner brothers acquired the film
adaptation rights to the game as part of
their acquisition of midway games in
2009 for 33 million dollars and i guess
it was worth it because the film grossed
over 428 million bucks worldwide against
an overall budget of 260 million and
with a rotten tomato meter score of 51
percent the consensus from critics is
that rampage isn't as fun as its source
material but the movie's sheer
button-mashing abandon might satisfy
audiences in the mood for a brandless
blockbuster
tomb raider 2018.
the next film on our list is tomb raider
and the answer to your next question is
not the other one this is the 2018 one
not the one with angelina the film is
based on the 2013 video game of the same
name which much like the movie was a
reboot of the franchise and rebuilds
lara croft's origins it also shares a
few minor elements of the sequel game
rise of the tomb raider from 2015.
alicia vikander stars as lara croft who
heads out on a risky journey to the last
known destination of her father an
offbeat adventurer who went missing
years earlier this brings larry to the
fabled tomb on a mythical island where
she has to rely on her strong mind faith
and spirit as she takes on the unknown
dominic west walton goggins daniel wu
and kristen scott thomas also appear
alongside vikander who said she was a
fan of the video games growing up and
wanted to make it as realistic as
possible so she put on 12 pounds of
muscle and did a bunch of her own stunts
that's a badass of course the rollway
clara croft only comes along once so
it's no surprise that every actress
under the sun was rumored for the park
before vikander landed it like emilia
clarke emma watson jennifer lawrence
circa ronan and elizabeth olsen to name
just a few coincidentally tomb raider
grossed 274 million dollars worldwide
the same as angelina jolie's 2001 film
although this time around it reportedly
needed to gross at least 275 million
dollars to break even
so close
you messed with the wrong family
[Music]
there will eventually be a sequel to
this one with vikander returning which
is a good thing considering she was a
bright spot for critics like robert
daniels from 812 film reviews who said
that she kills in every segment she's in
and the overall consensus from critics
is that tomb raider reboots the
franchise with a more grounded approach
and a star who's clearly more than up to
the task neither of which are well
served by an uninspired origin story
mortal kombat 2021
next up on this list again is mortal
kombat but this time it's the 2021
version still based on the video game
franchise of the same name this is a
reboot of the film series and was
directed by simon mcquoid in his
featured directorial debut the film
follows a washed up mma fighter named
cole young played by louis tan who is
unaware that he has a hidden lineage and
also has no idea why an assassin named
sub-zero is currently hunting him so in
an effort to protect his family cole
tracks down sonja blade played by
jessica mcnamee and ends up at the
temple of ward raiden the protector of
the earth realm there he trains with
warriors like the mercenary kano played
by josh lawson as they prepare for a
battle against the enemies of the
outworld with the universe on the line
no big deal also in the cast is max wang
a former member of the jackie chan stunt
team who would pitch ideas on set to
help make the film's fight choreography
even better it was a long time coming
for this reboot after mortal kombat
annihilation the 97 sequel to the
original film which i can't stress
enough you should not watch it was such
a critical and commercial failure but it
led to nearly two decades of what the
industry loves to call development hell
before things finally got going with
this reboot
[Music]
um
[Music]
it was finally released in april of 2021
both in theaters and streaming on hbo
max ultimately grossing 83 million
dollars at the worldwide box office
against the 55 million dollar budget and
becoming hbo max's most successful film
to date at the time but the graphic
violence which when translated from a
video game to real life can be a bit
more intense led to an initial nc 17
rating so several gory fight scenes were
edited down to fit under an r rating
whereas the 95 version was coming in
rated r and edited down to land a peachy
13 rating a sequel is officially in the
works for this one which is good news
for audiences who loved it and the
consensus from critics is that it's
largely for fans of the source material
but far from fatally flawed mortal
kombat revives the franchise in
appropriately violent fashion sonic the
hedgehog this is the island where i'm
from
it had everything sandy beaches
cascading waterfalls public access to
loop-de-loops and i never had to catch a
school bus because i could run across
the entire island in less than two
seconds
also there was no school i know pretty
sweet island right
speeding its way onto this list as the
first fresh film we've seen today is
2020's sonic the hedgehog this
adaptation was directed by jeff fowler
in his directorial debut and stars ben
schwartz as the voice of sonic in it the
speedy blue hedgehog teams up with a
local town sheriff played by james
marsden as they race across the globe to
try and stop the mad scientist dr
robotnik played by jim carrey who wants
to use sonic superpowers to conquer the
earth development for a sonic film began
not long after the video game first
graced the sega genesis in 1991 it was
in the hands of sony at one point before
paramount pictures acquired it in 2017.
but when the first original trailer for
this movie was finally released in april
of 2019 the backlash over the way the
character looked was swift and loud
people weren't really into sonic's teeth
or his legs or his head size but for the
first time in the history of anything
ever the powers that be were actually
hearing what the fans were saying and
fowler announced that the changes would
be made as the release date was pushed
to valentine's day 2020 because nothing
says romance and date night like a sonic
the hedgehog movie
[Music]
this is my power and i'm not using it to
run away anymore
i'm using it to protect my friends
but i suppose the full-on makeover and
delay was worth it because sonic set the
record for the biggest opening weekend
for a video game film in north america
eventually hauling in almost 320 million
dollars as the sixth highest grossing
film of 2020 plus like i mentioned
critics were finally feeling a video
game movie like breakfast all day's
christy lemire who said if you want a
light fun escape this is it and the
overall critic's consensus is that
fittingly fleet and frequently fun sonic
the hedgehog is a video game inspired
adventure the whole family can enjoy and
a fine excuse for jim carrey to tap into
the manic energy that launched his
career
pokemon detective pikachu
listen up
we got ways to make you talk or mine
yeah so tell us what we want to know why
was harry goodman here and what did it
have to do with the r
pipe yes okay i can
shoving pushing my problem is that i
push people away and then hate them for
leaving he's saying you can shove it
what i can shove it okay that's it no
we're switching roles i'm bad cop you're
good cop taking a peek at the next movie
on the list will bring us to 2019 with
pokemon detective pikachu the film is
based on the pokemon franchise and is a
loose adaptation of the 2016 video game
detective pikachu it was directed by rob
letterman known for movies like
gulliver's travels and goosebumps ryan
reynolds stars as the voice and facial
motion capture of detective pikachu who
joins forces with a 21 year old named
tim played by justice smith the only
human who can talk with pikachu and the
son of an ace detective after tim's
father goes missing the pair team up to
unravel the mystery among those
considered for the uh i guess coveted
role of pikachu were danny devito dwayne
johnson mark wahlberg and hugh jackman
before ryan reynolds got the call and
the trading card and bringing pikachu to
life so vivid and yellow was the same
team behind films like the jungle book
fantastic beasts and where to find them
and the lion king not a bad resume this
marked the first ever live-action
pokemon film and the first live-action
film based on a nintendo property since
super mario brothers in 1993. if you're
waiting for that movie to pop up on our
list don't hold your breath
i got a plan what that's not gonna work
magikarp is the worst magikarp can have
open to gyarados all these is a little
kick water in the hole
in my head i saw that differently and
this one was definitely an improvement
in the box office department grossing
433 million dollars worldwide becoming
the second highest grossing video game
movie ever after 2016's warcraft which
was also produced by legendary pictures
and with a fresh score of 68 on the
tomato meter the contestants from
critics is that pokemon detective
pikachu may not take its wonderfully
bizarre premise as far as it could have
but this offbeat adaptation should catch
most if not all of the franchises fans
the angry birds movie two
fire another ice ball uh
we can't do that zeta wait you're
torturing the engineer
hello
my limbs are beginning to numb
oh yeah i forgot about this look up it's
a drone it's a plane nope it's 2019's
angry birds movie 2. the film is based
on rovio entertainment's angry birds
video game series which first sprung
onto our phones in 2009. this is the
sequel to the angry birds movie from
2016 which stars jason sedakis josh gad
danny mcbride maya rudolph tony hale
bill hader and peter dinklage and with
leslie jones tiffany haddish aquafina
sterling k brown and jojo siwa joining
in on the fun this time around the
hijinx for aplenty it picks up three
years after the events of the first film
when some aggressive birds from an
ice-covered island are threatening to
destroy the foul and swine way of life
so the birds and pigs agree to put aside
their differences and unite to fight the
common threat they assemble their best
and brightest from both sides to figure
out a way to infiltrate the island and
save the day oddly enough 2019 was a
crazy busy year for animated sequels
with frozen 2 which also features josh
gadgets throwing kate brown along with
the lego movie 2 the second part and the
secret life of pets 2 both of which
include tiffany haddish that's my dad i
have a daughter yes you do and i raised
her all by myself in this icy wasteland
but now i'm going to be sipping pina
coladas on those warm tropical islands
like i deserve to
and this particular animated sequel did
okay at the box office with nearly 153
million dollars worldwide which is less
than the first film but it received much
more favorable reviews with critics and
fans and is considered an improvement
which is a rarity for any sequel and
speaking of critics the ap's jocelyn
novak said that this film reminds us
that finding a formula to appeal to both
kids and parents for 90 odd minutes is
not rocket science with an overall
consensus from critics that says like
its non-aerodynamic title characters the
angry birds movie 2 takes improbable yet
delightfully entertaining flight landing
humorous hits along the way
werewolves within uh out of curiosity
who is packing i am yes sir america
wow i have dave's hunting rifle if that
would be helpful oh gosh i almost forgot
um
i got oh my god it's teensy it's just a
little it's a little it's first time
okay and finally how on its way to the
top spot on this list of the highest
rated video game movies is 2021's
certified fresh werewolves within this
comedy horror film is based on the
multiplayer vr game of the same name
from red storm entertainment for oculus
rift htc vive and the playstation vr the
film stars sam richardson as a forest
ranger named finn and melania vaintrub
was a postal worker named cecily
together they try to keep the peace in a
town that is trapped together in a
snowstorm while also fighting over a
proposed pipeline and they have to
figure out the truth behind a mysterious
creature that is terrorizing the
community it's been a hard day's night
the film was directed by josh rubin in
just his second feature league film with
a screenplay written by mishna wolfe a
humorist and best-selling author in her
first and only film writing credit and
together they put out what is the
highest rated film based on a video game
on both rotten tomatoes and metacritic
as of march 2022 and while the video
game has set a medieval village and the
film is set in the modern day reuben was
still able to have fun with the wardrobe
which as he said was deliberately
exaggerated in the hope that someday
someone may want to dress up as these
characters for halloween or maybe a
comic book convention afraid i can't do
that ranger wheeler you could be one of
them
one of what
i like
[Music]
a what
werewolf this movie also has a couple of
fun knots so some fellow ubisoft video
games including wayne duval's character
using a hidden blade that's mounted on
his wrist one that appears in several
assassins creed games and sarah burns's
character gwen wearing a short ballast
jersey which is the fictional hockey
team featured in the game the division
just a few of the many things that made
this movie a hit with both fans and
movie reviewers with a consensus from
critics that werewolves within is the
rare hard comedy that offers equal
helpings of either genre and adds up to
a whole lot of fun in the bargain and
there you have it 10 glorious levels of
the highest rated video game movies
thanks for checking out our list and i'm
sorry if we've made you excited for both
watching these movies and then playing
these games or the reverse order just
practice good time management it's gonna
be okay thanks for checking out rt
essentials i'm mark ellis and remember
that's uh down down left right left
right a b select the spread is my fit
forget it i'm gonna turn off the console
and just play game boy
[Music]
[Music]